hey guys it's Justine in today's video
I'm going to show you this app called
descript now many of you may have heard
of this app before it's been around for
quite a while and a lot of people use it
for podcasting so it's been really
incredible for turning audio into
transcripts but recently descript has
started working more with video now this
is really really cool because if you
know how to edit a Word document hit
deletes type a few Keys you basically
are now becoming a video editor using
descript so a huge thank you to descript
for partnering with me on this video to
show you guys this they just had a
massive update with a lot of new
features and it really feels like after
you see this if you've never experienced
this before that anybody can become a
video editor within seconds so I want to
give you a little overview of how the
app works but also show you some of the
new features that they've just added
like being able to add stock footage AI
background removal making social clips
from longer videos and using scenes to
edit so to get started we're going to go
to new project what makes it so
different is you're basically going to
upload your video and it's going to
transcribe it automatically for you so
you're not going to be using this normal
timeline editor that a lot of us are
used to you're going to be editing with
scenes with text and there is a timeline
editor at the bottom which you will
sometimes have to reference and you can
actually use it and edit in there as
well but this is made to be edited with
text it's so cool so this is going to be
quitting caffeine now we're going to
choose our file to transcribe I have
already have this video shot so we're
adding the file in it's uploading it to
descript so it's preparing and now we're
going to add our speaker name Justine
that is me there's so many features that
descript has to offer and I'm probably
not going to get to all of them but one
thing that I really like while this is
preparing is your a able to over dub
your voice basically making vo but not
having to go and actually record video
you could type the words that you want
it to speak and because you already have
this full script this full transcript of
your voice descript is able to use AI I
basically make vo for you this is the
entire transcript that was pretty fast
thankfully I do have very fast internet
so this video did upload pretty quickly
so to get started editing you'll see
over here on this side we've got just
one little image here and this little
slash using slashes is how you're going
to separate scenes in descript instead
of making Cuts you just delete text I
know I I know hey guys it's Justine and
you may have seen me talking about this
on Twitter a little bit
we can type a slash or you can click
here to add a scene I like typing a
slash now I love doing jump cuts and
punches so this right here is separating
everything out by scenes so if I want to
take this I like punching in so I'm
gonna Zoom myself in
and everyone's like wow that's so cool
of you that's it that's all that's I
just I typed a slash and it just
magically happened you might also be
curious why a lot of these words are
underlined well I'm glad that you were
curious and I'm glad that you asked
because these are filler words I have a
terrible habit of saying like
um us random words that I don't want in
my video and you might not actually see
them very often because I edit them out
but with this you can remove all of the
filler words automatically 70 results of
kind of I do say kind of a lot
um you know like that's a lot so we're
just gonna go ahead and delete all of
them so we're gonna remove the media I
don't want to replace it with gap Clips
I just want them all to go away we're
now deleting every single redundant word
so this whole section I kind of messed
up on so you can see I say long story
short well guess what I also say it down
here as well so we're just gonna
delete it so now that has made this
whole entire thing caffeine you may have
seen I got a blood clot at my shoulder
another scene now up here you'll see
there's a little bit of space I don't
like that so down here you're able to
drag this and you can basically remove
that dead air drinking caffeine you may
have seen I got on the clot of my
shoulder it's so cool
seems like it did a pretty good job of
seeing like where I'd kind of want those
breaks to be but now is where the really
fun part comes in this is kind of a
boring video I'm just sitting here
talking let's spice it up with a little
bit of stock footage so here I want to
find a blood clot stock image so let's
go into video and we're gonna search for
blood clot I don't even know if
anything's gonna show up okay this is
actually perfect it's downloading the
media it automatically has added it and
caffeine you may have seen I got a blood
clot at my shoulder I'm talking about
quitting caffeine so let's do oh yeah
that's a good one
little coffee this is great I'm gonna
have so much stock footage in all my
videos now you guys are gonna be like
Wow have you been going out shooting all
day long to get all of this b-roll nope
as painful as that was all the needles
and all of the surgeries and all of the
things that I had to go through caffeine
withdrawals let's put something here we
also can add gifs stickers
let's do shock
here we go oh my God here we go this is
perfect through caffeine withdrawals oh
my God it's so good
now I'm going to take out the background
of this video we're gonna do green
screen obviously this isn't a green
screen but using AI it's able to
obviously detect I am a person I want to
remove everything except me while the
green screen is adding I'm going to find
a background
this looks good
I'm gonna add that
here now this clip is on top of our
green screen clip so I'm going to right
click here and I'm going to send this to
the back now this is going to bring me
to the front in my green screen Glory
and I could also resize myself
which we're gonna do
like this is so easy
it's like hurting my mind something's
wrong like
I knew that I was addicted to caffeine
but I didn't realize how bad it was it
also had sound effects we can add music
we can do all sorts of things in here so
let's add a sound effect
tomorrow
okay yeah that sounds great
let's add that on right here
I knew that I was addicted to caffeine
but I didn't realize how bad it was we
could also add music to the entire track
so we're gonna do music let's find a
little song shall we oh that's nice
and you'll notice I haven't really
messed much in this timeline but yes you
can also make edits and adjust things in
the timeline as well and turn that audio
down a little oh but April 1st I titles
I love titles there's another cool thing
here that you can do you can obviously
just add some text
there we go I wrote this on Twitter a
little bit so you can't actually make
your own templates but they have some
intros annotations overlays frames and
audiograms which we'll talk about in a
second so let's just use a little intro
here already
hey guys it's just
and you may have seen me talking about
this on Twitter a little bit we're gonna
add a little annotation
follow me Instagram and I kind of want
that to be a little longer so I can drag
down here and that'll automatically
adjust it up here with the slashes if
you follow me Instagram Tech talk I
don't even know now my video was shot in
the studio so my audio is pretty decent
I am wearing a microphone but a lot of
times when people are making videos they
may just be shooting them on their
computer this gives you the ability to
go in and add some audio effects to
repair the audio and add Studio sound so
this actually does make a pretty big
difference so I'm glad that they do have
this available now inside of the effects
you could also change and adjust the
color thankfully again my color is
pretty decent but if I wanted to adjust
this I can go into the color adjustments
adjust the exposure contrast I can
adjust the highlights Shadows add some
saturation and adjust the color
temperature don't judge that it was just
for the sake of showing you how it works
something that I've been struggling with
a lot as a Creator is you have all of
this content now how do we export that
for various social platforms so descript
can make it super simple to take chunks
of this video and re export it out for
social media so we've already got a
couple little things edited so I'm going
to take this whole section here and I
can click duplicate to new composition
so this is adding it to a whole new
composition now I want to make this
vertical for tick tock so we're going to
do portrait so you can resize all of
these clips I'm gonna pop myself here
we're going to add the doctor footage
below surgeries and all the things that
I had to go through so we've got our
video all formatted and something that I
like to add on a lot of my social Clips
is captions because a lot of vertical
content is viewed without sound so being
able to add these captions not only
helps people who are hard of hearing but
it also helps those who don't have sound
on when you're probably scrolling in a
place that you shouldn't like work we're
gonna go into shape
we're going to click waveform you can
change the style put our lines here and
we're also going to add some captions so
you know how you see those really great
social media videos where they have the
text that pops up automatically well
guess what we can do that too so we're
going to add the captions and we're
going to have it set up so that it
highlights the word that is being spoken
all the needles and all of the surgeries
and all of the we're gonna have these
captions actually be on this entire
video so we're just going to drag that
all out because that experience in the
hospital as painful as that was and
that's it we now have a really fun
social media clip it's vertical we have
little waveforms to show that there's
actually some speaking and sound
happening and you can have the text at
the bottom so you'll be able to read
them instead of having to listen to it
now once you're done with your video you
can hit publish this will give you a
couple different options so you can
actually just export this video or you
could hit publish so you can publish
this to a web link to YouTube or a bunch
of other various media platforms so I'm
just going to export it and we're going
to export this 4K I want this to be in
high high quality what's that sport this
is the video that we just made it's
about putting caffeine because that
experience in the hospital now showing
how to shorten the word gaps manually
but you can also go in here and shorten
word gaps automatically which is such a
Time Saver sometimes you may want a
little bit of pause in between your
words I don't like that so I'm going to
apply this to all of them it shortened
11 word gaps and that has saved me so
much time in my video so sometimes there
are words that it doesn't get correct so
this is supposed to say yerba mate there
it is again
I really need to correct that so now I
want to add a little bit of VO here so
I'm going to write
overdub this we're going to assign a
voice
new voice Justine record your voice ID
voice training has started okay let's
see what it sounds like hello I'm
writing this in post this is what it
would sound like if I had to re-record
something and that's my voice but it's
not my voice I mean it is my voice but
it's not this is the future everyone
can't hate on AI too much because if I
don't have to go and get this whole
setup and re-record all of the stuff and
I can just do this and it sounds that
good sign me up another thing that I
really like are these audiograms so
basically I did make this little
template already for myself in the
vertical format but I can add a template
here that's already made and I won't
actually have to do anything it'll
automatically make it for me so that was
a look at dscript I am so excited about
this app and I think it's so much fun
and I think it's going to be a huge
asset to a lot of video creators
podcasters basically anyone that's
creating content because it gives you
this whole other element and a way of
editing that has not been there before I
would love to hear what you guys think
of this if you want to check it out
there is a link in the description you
can get a free trial and please please
tell me what you think of it because
it's really freaking cool and I'm so
excited about it if you guys haven't
already be sure to subscribe hit the
Bell to be notified when I post new
videos and of course leave me those
comments below and I will see you guys
in the comment section
[Music]